all right welcome to hannity breaking
big tonight
a lot of news big new promising
developments from
america's search for a corona virus
vaccine
just had a talk with a very prominent
medical doctor who
is more than optimistic we will share
this good news with you tonight
and buckle up we are now just 112 days
away
what has now emerged into the single
biggest
choice election in modern american
history
not an exaggeration not hyperbole
if let's see look at joe's team if joe
biden wins
if he has the strength and stamina and
mental alertness to do the job
if he implements the extreme agenda that
he's now embracing
let me be clear america as you know it
we know it will be destroyed our entire
way of life will be flushed down the
drain
if the issue of law and order security
and safety if that matters to you and to
your family
if free market capitalism matters to you
and your family if our constitution the
rule of law
matters to you here's what you need to
know in 112 days you are the ultimate
jury
joe biden doesn't well really have any
original ideas he never has
he's been in the swamp 50-plus years
it's 50 years of elect me and i'll do
this
i'll do this as the president says all
talk talk talk
no action schumer pelosi and biden alone
125 combined years of elect me
and i'll promise this this and this
nothing but 125 years of
meaningless promises and unmitigated
failure
oh and on biden's part lots of
plagiarism remember he's accused of
plagiarizing a paper in law school
the 1980s many of his speeches were
plagiarized he was accused of
plagiarizing robert kennedy hubert
humphrey
british mp neil kinnick we played that
for you last week and the scary part
is biden has now taken his cues from the
most radical
the most extreme socialist extremists
that this party has ever embraced the
democratic modern socialist party
look at the corrupt forgetful joe biden
team
you got biden schumer pelosi that's 125
years of well failure alone
now add to that bernie sanders uh
congresswoman ocasio-cortez
beto bozo o'rourke gunzar
his latest policy proposals were
literally
authored by the devout socialist bernie
sanders
and joe even plagiarized bernie's agenda
literally in many instances word for
word
right out of bolshevik bernie socialist
platform
now keep in mind bernie wants the
government to control all means of
production
he wants to nationalize industry like
they did in venezuela and cuba
he's praised those regimes and by the
way honeymoon in the former soviet union
meanwhile socialist congresswoman
ocasio-cortez
she's in charge of biden's climate task
force
and she wants to ban oil gas coal air
travel and eventually even cows
says we have 12 years and it's all over
her green new deal will cost
94 trillion dollars over 10 years
that will turn america into a socialist
bankrupt hell hole
and then of course there's biden's gun
control czar beto bozo o'rourke
whose top priority is to literally take
your guns away
this is what's at stake in 112 days take
a look
hell yes we're going to take your ar-15
your ak-47
i'm going to guarantee you this and not
last year's scene of this guy
you're going to take care of the gun
problem with me
okay to recap biden has tapped bolshevik
bernie
he's even plagiarizing him to lead his
economic policies
aoc will lead the green new deal climate
task force beta bozo
he's coming for your guns and by the way
he also has schumer and pelosi in
congress
uh this is his team right there
and add beto and add aoc they win and
you can start singing
bye bye miss american pie because it's
over
what's next is he gonna now tap uh let's
see the ever
incompetent cuomo to what leader's
coronavirus task force
is he gonna tap comrade de blasio of
mayor of new york
as his law and orders are after all just
last week
biden in his own words he agreed that
yes funds should be diverted away from
the police in other words
he's embraced the defund the police
movement he's the guy that said
last week police have now become the
enemy
in new york city comrade de blasio
already slashed the nypd budget by a
billion dollars
he's disbanded the undercover the most
effective anti-crime unit in the city
he's banned all stop and frisk
meanwhile new york governor cuomo well
he's the genius to let thousands of
violent criminals out of jail
every single time with this idiotic zero
dollar
uh bail policy and as a result what are
we seeing
shootings in new york city and new york
state they have more than doubled over
the last year on monday
at least 17 people shot that includes
three drive-by shootings at one point
over the weekend
there was a shooting every single hour
and last night we brought you lawrence
jones's
heart-wrenching interview with the
family of that one-year-old
baby boy who was shot and killed he was
in a stroller he was in a playground
in brooklyn now this violence is
unacceptable it comes as police
all over the country now are now under
attack since may
12 police officers have now been killed
in the line of duty
two were murdered over the weekend in
texas while responding to a domestic
disturbance call
over a thousand other police officers
seriously injured
rocks and bottles and bricks and molotov
cocktails knives and guns being used
against them
the chaos the carnage in america's big
liberal cities
it's out of control and by the way if
you want a preview of coming attractions
that will be america with biden pelosi
aoc schumer and beto that's your choice
we can't make it any more clear you are
the ultimate jury so do you want in 112
days
law in order to be restored or do you
want it to get worse
because biden wants to defund the police
and abolish cash
cash bail just like they did in new york
he's come a long way from calling people
predators
and you know well saying other
incendiary things on
on racial issues like he didn't want his
kids in a racial jungle if we're talking
about integration he used those words
like i said at the top this has now
become
the single biggest greatest choice
election in our lifetime
on every single important issue that
will impact
your kids your life and your grandkids
do you want biden's plans for open
borders for amnesty
the united sanctuary states of america
the minute you get into america you get
absolutely free health care free free
free
free schools for every illegal immigrant
and amnesty
what do you prefer border security 400
miles
of border wall will be built by election
day
you get to decide do you want biden's
tax increases that he is promising
or do you prefer lower taxes that donald
trump is promising
do you want biden's green new deal
madness or president trump
let's see he's made this country energy
independent for the first time in over
75 years
and he's also made it for the first time
in 75 years we are now the world's
number one producer
of energy do you want that or do you
want to ban
coal and fracking and oil production do
you want biden's activist judges
legislating for the bench do you want to
stack the courts like well democrats
have been talking about
or do you prefer constitutionalists
those who believe
that as the fundamental rule of law for
the united states of america
do you want socialized health care do
you want to keep your private health
care how did obamacare biden care work
out for you do you want hunter biden
making sketchy billion dollar deals with
the bank of china
lining his own pockets or do you want a
president who will actually stand
up to china as this president did
earlier today
you want zero experience hunter making
millions more in ukraine
quid pro quo joe zero experience hunter
uh
worked out perfectly didn't it as
president trump said today there's never
been a time when two candidates were so
different
let's watch the president
it's probably never been a time when
candidates are so different
we want law and order they don't want
law and order
we want strong closed borders with
people able to come in through merit
through
a legal process they don't want to have
any borders at all they're going to rip
down the wall
it was hard to get that built and now
it's
almost completed ultimately
i'm only one vote my vote's probably not
going to mean much in new york it comes
down
to you you the american people you are
the
jury here do you want america to become
a place
where working hard doing the right thing
is punished
mob rule anarchy is rewarded because
that's what biden is now selling with
his team of pelosi schumer
aoc bernie and bozo
but that's those are the stakes in 112
days
you're the ultimate jury you get to
shock the world again
and you get to stop what they want to do
to this country
from happening you know it would
certainly be worthwhile
just for the pure entertainment purposes
to watch the fake news media mob in this
country i'm just thinking out loud
in 112 days maybe early into 113 days
early in the morning having to
choke on the words we can now project
that donald j trump has been re-elected
the 45th president of the united states
um
how do you think that's going to go over
when you get the call that they
we get to watch them make that call
that'd be pretty amazing
we survived eight years of obama i don't
want to go back
you know what america was resilient this
plan is
way beyond anything that has ever been
proposed the most radical extreme
socialist proposals in the history of
this country
it will destroy the u.s freedom that has
created more wealth more
opportunity that we have used for human
advancement around the world that's all
because of liberty and freedom
and every time you get a false promise
of security you give up your freedoms